a man who dares to waste one hour of
time
has not discovered the value of life
if the misery of the poor is caused not
by the laws of nature but by our
institutions
great is our sin
we stopped looking for monsters under
our bed
when we realized
that they were inside us
[Music]
the love for all living creatures
is the most noble attribute of man
the highest possible stage in moral
culture
is when we recognize that we ought to
control our thoughts
blushing is the most peculiar
and most human of all expressions
sympathy for someone else's joy
is a much rarer gift
than sympathy for someone else's
suffering
[Music]
intelligence is based on how efficient a
species
becomes at doing the things they need to
survive
man selects only for his own good
nature only for that of the being
which she tends
great is the power of steady
misrepresentation
it is always advisable to perceive
clearly
our ignorance
[Music]
it is not the strongest of the species
that survives
but the most adaptable
we are always slow in admitting any
great change of which we do not see the
intermediate steps
the very essence of instinct
is that it's followed independently of
reason
[Music]
a scientific man ought to have no wishes
no affections
a mere heart of stone
[Music]
in conclusion
it appears that nothing can be more
improving to a young
naturalist than a journey in distant
countries
the more we know the immutable laws of
nature
the more incredible miracles become for
us
there is nothing more unbearable
than idleness
to those who fully recognize the
immorality of the human soul
the death of our world will seem less
terrible
we must however acknowledge
as it seems to me
that man with all his noble qualities
still bears in his bodily frame
the indelible stamp
of his lowly origin
marrying is not at all difficult
it is difficult
to be married
one original law leading to the
advancement of all organic beings
namely
multiply
very
let the strongest live
and the weakest die
[Music]
man
in his arrogance
thinks himself a great work
worthy of the interposition of a deity
more humble and i believe truer
to consider him created from animals
[Music]
share secrets with those who have no
friends
be friends only with those
who have many friends
[Music]